uh there is more paper trail
where because of newly released emails
we have learned in the last 24 hours
that Donald Trump and his administration
were pressuring the Department of
Justice to challenge the election
results of the 2020 election to try to
help Trump stay in power this is it's
just every day is more the New York
Times reports that an hour before
President Donald Trump announced in
December that William Barr would step
down as attorney general the president
began pressuring Mr Barr's eventual
replacement to have the justice
department take up his false claims of
election fraud Trump sent an email via
his assistant Jeffrey Rosen the incoming
I'm sorry via his assistant to Jeffrey
Rosen the incoming acting attorney
general containing documents purporting
to show evidence of election fraud in
northern Michigan the same name claims
that a judge had thrown out a week
earlier in a lawsuit filed by one of
Trump's personal lawyers
another email from Trump to Mr Rosen
followed two weeks later again via the
president's assistant that included a
draft of a brief that Mr Trump wanted
the justice department to file to the
Supreme Court it argued among other
things that state officials had used the
pandemic to weaken election security and
pave the way for widespread election
fraud it simply will not stop it's
another example of Donald Trump abusing
his power as president to try to
strong-arm people to steal the election
for him it's that simple and that's the
language we should use about it Trump
called the Georgia election officials
remember Secretary of State Brad
raffensberger and others and said we
just need to find 11 780 votes that's
all and then Donald Trump had Rudy
Giuliani all over the country pushing
all sorts of bogus nonsense and now we
learn Trump was pressuring the justice
department to help him in doing the
exact same it is really time to start
Prosecuting members of the Trump
Administration if not Trump himself
there's just no other option here and of
course if they did it it would be called
out as completely partisan by the
Republican party but if this in some
total doesn't warrant prosecution what
does is quite quite literally
if we don't prosecute over this we're
going back to that Nixon idea of if the
president does it it's not illegal
remember how many investigations and
hearings they had about Benghazi that
they successfully were able to hold in
order to try to hurt Hillary Clinton
politically and now look at what's going
on now some of you might say this is
just too much even for Trump supporters
finally it's just everything's coming up
the Trump supporters are finally going
to be convinced to abandon Donald Trump
because of this or because of the next
thing no way no they will say the report
is fake news or they will say well no
Trump had to do it because it was Biden
who stole the election from him so Trump
had to go to the justice department and
to Lobby the Supreme Court to give him
the election because Biden's the one who
stole it and Guys these are the people
who when the power went out in Texas
because of that isolationist right-wing
decision to totally separate the the
Texas power grid from the rest of the
country these are the right Wingers who
said the the reason the power went out
is wind power it's wits Frozen windmills
that's the explanation for them the ends
justify the means and if they simply
believe that Donald Trump had to do it
to stop Joe Biden from stealing the
election and stop Joe Biden's socialism
they don't care
they don't care what Trump may have done
or may have tried to do to stay in power
so we it's been five years guys where we
say oh this this they they won't
tolerate now they're going to nope they
just look the other way or they excuse
it now one other thing there are people
saying don't prosecute Trump because of
fears of violence if you prosecute Trump
it's going to trigger even more violence
on the streets that may be true but it
can't be the reason that this is not
pursued
it just can't be Trump formed a
coalition of these ignorant and
sometimes violent people he weapon
weaponized their ignorance and
gullibility into the Trump riots and
more and then he weaponized their
gullibility into raising tens of
millions of dollars supposedly to fight
this fraud and to fight that fraud and
to recount this and that and then now
we're going to say listen they may
become even more violent if we do what
we need to do which is to actually
prosecute this that can't happen it
simply cannot be that that's the reason
why they're all allowed to get away with
it and by the way won't they be
emboldened in some sense if Trump and
everybody around Trump does end up
skating in the sense that they will have
done all of this huge list of things
won't have succeeded at getting Trump
back in power but they will have done it
all this attempt that attempt these lies
those bogus lawsuits the January 6 riots
on and on and on and no consequences
that will embolden them for the next
time and whether the next time is August
or 2022 or 2024 we don't yet know but we
can't say now they're going to get
violent if we prosecute so we can't do
it that that's not how the United States
of America works
I've struggled with eye strain because I
do use my computer screen a lot for the
work that I do and there are some
studies suggesting that blue light from
screens can cause headaches or eye
strain watery eyes in some cases even
trouble falling asleep but I've had no
issues since I started using blue blocks
glasses which filter out that blue light
and they're one of our sponsors blue
blocks glasses are made in actual Optics
Laboratories with an evidence-backed
design they have readers a prescription
version non-prescription Daytime
Nighttime lenses 40 different frames to
choose from these are my blue blocks
glasses they've been great no more
strain from the computer with blue
blocks glasses filtering out the blue
light go to blueblocks.com Pacman or
click the link below and there's free
shipping worldwide on orders over a
hundred and fifteen dollars and until
June 30th you'll actually get 25 off
orders over 160 dollars and thirty
percent off orders over 350 dollars